it's been about a week since Apple
surprised us with these new MacBook Pros
and I wanted to give you guys an update
on my experience upgrading from my
15-inch I almost forgot which one was -
the new 16 inch now this video isn't a
review which we are working on and taken
our time with to make sure that it's
filled with great detailed info that
many aren't talking about but in this
video I'll be sharing the real-world
differences that I noticed as I've been
using this new 16 inch MacBook Pro both
the good things and the bad first off
let's talk about the keyboard I know a
lot of people hate it on the butterfly
keys but I wasn't one of them
upgrading to these new keys did feel
better right off the bat but it wasn't a
huge deal to me personally but I do have
to say that I've been pretty lucky with
my butterfly keyboards not having any
issues that was until I got used to
these new keys and then switched back
wow these are way better and they are
not just the old pre butterfly keys but
from what I could tell they are the best
of both worlds with much larger key
travel and the reliability of the pre
2016 keys fused with the better
stability and more mechanical feel of
the butterfly keys overall these are a
major win I'm someone that really uses
my MacBook Pros mics so apart from that
first little comparison we did during
hands-on I haven't really needed to use
the so-called studio microphones that
are included with the MacBook Pro
because we have a lot of high quality
microphones but I have watched a few
videos on MacBook Pros where youtubers
would switch from the regular mics to
the MacBook Pro and then the MacBook Pro
would actually sound a lot better so I
do think that for a lot of people
they're actually gonna be able to use
these microphones in an upgrade from
what they already have or just not to
buy anything extra now let's talk about
a slight disappointment the speaker's
don't get me wrong they sound fantastic
the bass is much improved in the
separation of frequencies due to the
extra speakers is great but my
disappointment is volume
[Music]
[Music]
it's not bad still beating out most if
not all Windows laptops of similar size
and those that are actually bigger and
heavier but I did have several occasions
where I wish that they were louder
just like the 15-inch MacBook or that
came previously which are about three
decibels louder especially if you're
playing back in loud environments or if
you have a bunch of group of people say
and you want to show a trailer or
something like that it is nice to be
able to just crank it up now let's talk
about that 16 inch display to be honest
when I was hearing rumors about this new
MacBook I was hoping that with this
redesign we would get something like
what Dell offers with their infinity
edge displays but nope the bezels did
shrink a bit but it's not a big enough
difference to just jump out at you now
on the other hand if you have a 15-inch
MacBook Pro the larger 16 inches slate
definitely does jump out at you at first
and then when I went back to the 15-inch
that's when I really noticed the
difference in screen size and the bezels
with that said nobody should be
upgrading for the larger screen or the
better speakers alone now what you
should upgrade for is the graphics with
the release of the eight core MacBook
Pros there was a big boost in CPU
performance but the graphics stayed the
same meaning for tasks that really push
the GPU the CPU was actually
bottlenecked so how have the new 7
nanometre AMD Navi graphics been well
it's a mixed bag if you already have a
bag of 20 as I do the 550 M is
definitely much more powerful if you're
pushing your graphics to the extreme
limits say in video editing especially
in Bruce X where I saw a huge difference
or even bigger and blender where the
four gigs of video memory you've really
hammer it and bottled like the graphics
but in my regular use real world even
including some video editing using 4k
h.264 files and final cuts I didn't see
that much of a difference it really
matters what you are doing with your
computer and how heavy the graphics card
is being hit with that said if you have
a Mac without Vega graphics you will
definitely notice a difference even in
easier video editing now I will be doing
more in depth detail
testing with video editing across a
couple different editing programs and
codecs but that will be on my max yuryev
channel so go ahead and check that out
now we're graphics really come in is
gaming the Vega 20 MacBook was the first
portable Mac that could play triple-a
titles some way I decently and this
year's upgrade is a huge one the 5500 M
is about 50 percent faster than the Vega
20 which is a huge improvement just one
year later after the Vega but what is
even more impressive is the base 5300 M
which I also gamed with and that is
almost as powerful as the best option in
smokes the Vega 20 while costing 450
dollars less I know a lot of you guys
were asking about fortnight's so I did
play some in Mac OS and the experience
was great I was getting over 60 FPS at
1440p with mostly high settings if you
drop the resolution to just under 1080p
for perfect scaling you can play with
the settings maxed out super smooth no
issues at all
and that was actually on the base 16
inch macbook pro we also played the
latest call of duty with the 5500
amusing boot camp and had a great
experience staying above that 60 FPS
goal with medium settings out 1440p
resolution now the base i7 5300
performed basically the same but we are
thinking that is because these are brand
new drivers boot camp was just made
available to drivers and I know
performance is going to get better now
this isn't a gaming powerhouse so you
shouldn't buy it for gaming but what is
very important is that these base
graphics are now about three times as
fast as just a week ago and can actually
compete with Windows laptops like the
Dell XPS 15 which has a 1650 now Apple
really emphasizes the upgraded cooling
in this MacBook Pro and yes it does make
a difference in performance comparisons
but do you actually notice it in the
real world no not really the performance
difference is definitely there but
unless you're actually using a timer or
running benchmarks you're not really
gonna notice it so I say it is not
enough to warrant upgrading from the
same chips in a 15-inch chassis but one
thing that I did notice that was nicer
is that the fans are less annoying the
fans themselves have a deeper sound but
it's
about a decibel louder at full blast and
rendering videos I did notice the fans
more so but during less intensive tasks
and even doing some video editing the
fans run slower so overall it is
definitely an improvement now I wish I
can say that the battery life is also
better but at this time I really can't
tell I did do some kind of simple more
casual tests and actually seemed like
the sixteen-inch was draining more
battery but I don't want to say that
until I have some concrete evidence on
some more detail testing so I'll make
sure that is included in the full review
overall I am really impressed with the
new 16 inch MacBook Pro it is absolutely
a better machine all around but what is
even more important is that the value
proposition is massively better
especially with updated apps that use
metal you could honestly get similar if
not better performance this year on a
2400 our machine not this one I hear but
one that I've over there the base model
compared to last fall's MacBook Pro
which costs over $1,000 more just like
mine right here actually which does hurt
a bit but at the same time I am very
happy the Apple is making these changes
go ahead and click above on that circle
if you want to subscribe to see our full
detailed review which you do not want to
miss and click over there to see another
great MacBook Pro video this is an
actual smacks deck and I will see you in
the next one
[Music]